You don't know everything about
me i've lived a lot of lives
before i was an avenger
before i got this family i made mistakes
choosing between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
we have to go back to where it all started
where did you think i was all
this time have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest
girls in the world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we
played our roles it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
your such a mom
one thing's for sure
i'm done running for my past
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new black widow trailer video for disney plus
they just dropped a bunch of new footage even
though the movie isn't coming out till july 9th
so i'll explain what's going on and all the new
easter eggs they put into this obviously a whole
bunch more avengers footage tying her to avengers
end game the other avengers movies this is meant
to be a marvel phase 4 movie and push the story
of marvel phase 4 forward so we'll also explain
how they're doing that and tying it to the marvel
phase 4 stuff even though it's set during the past
before the events of avengers infinity war if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos and careful for spoilers for
the marvel phase 4 stuff that's already happened
like the Wandavision episodes in the falcon and
winter soldier episodes so far but just a reminder
that the movie is being released on disney plus on
july 9th through the disney premier access program
and in theaters on the same day i think by july
most theaters around the world will be open in
limited capacity so you can choose however you
want to watch it but most of the new footage in
this just highlights her secret backstory in the
mcu before she became a black widow before she
joined the black widow program which seems like it
goes back to the 90s just based on her age during
iron man 2. like very young teenager like middle
school aged version of black widow here they're
changing a little of her timeline in the mcu
from the comic book version of natasha blackwidow
same thing for taskmaster as well so i'll explain
how they change the taskmaster mcu backstory
because there's also a lot more taskmaster
footage explaining what's really going on with
his character as well turns out black widow and
taskmaster share more in common than you thought
but the brand new footage of this starts with
her as a little kid in the past like you see her
running up to their suburban house the way they
explained this is that the russians basically
planted them in the united states what seems
like back in the 90s to infiltrate the country
the same way you saw during the americans fx
series bunch of russian spies hiding out in
america pretending to be a regular american family
when secretly they're working for the soviets
but based on her age and when she went through the
black widow program it sounds like even though the
soviet union may have collapsed in the 90s the
black widow program itself continued under the
new russian government because during falcon and
winter soldier episode three just sort of tying
this to the marvel phase four stuff and the new
story that they're explaining the weapons plus
program the brand new super soldier program they
sort of tie to what was happening around this era
because when this flashback is happening it's
pretty close to the time when winter soldier
and hydra are stealing the super soldier serum
from howard stark but that was hydra working on
their own separate from the black widow program
in the russian government so the russian military
is behind the black widow program that was a state
military-sponsored program all the stuff that was
happening with the winter soldier program that was
all just hydra over off by themselves in siberia
so when nagel is explaining the history of the
weapons plus program in his new super soldier
serum he's explained that basically after this
failed attempt at the winter soldier program after
all these super soldiers that hydra created went
rogue they put them on ice because they weren't
very reliable they brought nagel in for a couple
years to perfect the serum but then you have the
events of captain america winter soldier hydra
collapses that's when the cia brought him on to
reverse engineer isaiah bradley's super soldier
serum for the americans but then you have the
events of avengers infinity war the snap and then
he explains that when he got blipped back by the
hulk's infinity gauntlet snap they basically put
the program on hiatus and that's when he wound up
in madrapur working for the power broker so the
cool marvel phase four connection here people
are expecting some sort of loose super soldier
serum plot connected to this like in the comics
black widow does have a diluted form of the super
soldier serum in her blood which makes her way
stronger not quite as strong as say like captain
america because it's a weaker version of the serum
that he was given but the whole thing with red
guardians character is that he is the russian
version of captain america they gave him a version
of the serum that they reverse engineered although
that would have happened around the same time they
were creating the hydra super soldiers in the 90s
so you do wonder who created the russians version
of the super soldier serum because it's supposed
to be different from the hydra winter soldier
program version of the serum that they stole from
howard stark i think nagel implied during falcon
winter soldier episode 3 that they were all the
different governments around the world that were
trying to reverse engineer their own versions of
the serum and he just happened to be the one to
perfect it but whatever the case the whole deal
with the plot of the black widow movie is that
they've revived the black widow program because i
guess it went defunct for a little while they make
it seem like taskmaster is running the program
but really you see that he's just the puppet of
drakoff here and if you remember the drakoff's
daughter easter egg from the first avengers movie
based on the trailer it seems like drakoff is
really the person who's behind the black widow
program he is a comic book character but they've
changed him a little bit from the comics so in
the comics there's this man that basically adopts
black widow like a military person then he's the
person who takes her to the black widow program
but in the mcu drakeoff is just a russian general
who's always part of the black widow program
and the official character synopsis for him in
the black widow movie is that he's the person
who recruited natasha black widow for the program
but that happened after these flashback scenes
that you're seeing with her as a little girl like
you see rachel vice's black widow character saying
we all played our roles and you see a couple
other black widows in russian military pulling
them apart so it sounds like whatever happens in
these flashback scenes something goes sideways in
america with their infiltration plan but they
start to feel like a real family like you have
florence pugh's character saying it felt real
to me even though rachel weiss's character is
saying no no this was all meant to be fake then
it seems like present day you have dracoff pulling
taskmaster's strings saying bring her home which
is probably talking either about florence pugh's
version of black widow or natasha's black widow
like bring them back into the program so they're
trying to give taskmaster this sort of parallel
character arc to the natasha black widow character
like she narrates in the trailer like she
narrates during the trailer at a certain
point you have to choose what the world
wants you to be versus what you want to be
so when she says i made my choice that's basically
when she defected came to america started working
with nick fury hawkeye shield and then eventually
the avengers you have florence pugh's character
talking about how all these new black widows have
no will whatsoever they're kind of like puppets
working under taskmaster and drake off but it also
kind of seems like taskmaster himself is a puppet
of drakoff so he himself will have to break free
of that control during the movie even though he
is kind of one of the villains during the film
i think we're all kind of expecting them to save
him for future thunderbolts spin-off stories like
they won't kill him off at the end of the movie
and they'll portray him as more of an anti-hero
so that it makes sense when he would eventually
theoretically join a thunderbolts team it's the
same thing they're doing with baron zemo on falcon
and winter soldier right now like in episode
three he seems more like an anti-hero than just
like a straight-up mustache twirling villain
especially with all those sick dance moves the
other big change it seems like they've made to his
character's backstory too the way his powers work
is that it's more practical than it is just
innately a special ability in the comics
the way they explain his powers is that he has
photographic memory and photographic reflexes so
when he's fighting one of the avengers characters
or a character like spider-man his brain learns
all their moves and because he has perfect recall
he can remember everything that he's ever seen he
can instantly devise a counter-attack that the
characters are weak against so like we see him
during the trailer it looks like he has all this
footage from the avengers movies and their fight
scenes like he's watching the airport battle
from captain america civil war so he learns all
their moves and then you see him using a bunch
of different avengers moves during his fight
with red guardian later like you see him use a
spider move with this jump kick flip then you see
him use a black panther move with the claws then
you see him use the captain america shield stomp
during the other footage when he's fighting black
widow on the bridge you see him copy her moves
he can do that for any character but obviously the
mcu version is just making a little more practical
with the way his gear integrates that and records
all of his fights it seems like he has a lot of
cameras built into his gear there also if you're
a big fan of the boys they kind of did the same
thing with black noir's character where you have
him running around with all these body cams and
you have giancarlo esposito's character watching
all this go down and speaking commands into his
ear so black noir is kind of like a finger
puppet for giancarlo esposito's character
it seems like that's the same relationship the
taskmaster has with drakoff here in the comics
the big difference though is that he's actually
an american character from new york city and he
mostly comes up working with the us military then
as a mercenary like he isn't really tied to the
russians or the soviets when he's growing up and
obviously the timeline is a little bit different
too i also like during this new trailer footage
that they show you the footage of black widow
wielding captain america shield because of all the
stuff that's happening with the shield on falcon
and winter soldier the reason why she's able
to use the shield so well is because she's so
highly trained as a fighter but also because the
shield itself is effectively weightless it's made
of vibranium which is an incredibly lightweight
material i think people got confused by that like
how can falcon throw the shield so much how can
new dark captain america throw the shield that way
if he doesn't have the super soldier serum yet
it's mostly just because it's a skill that you can
learn and the shield itself is very lightweight
it's just that when steve rogers captain america
is wielding the shield in all the avengers movies
the captain america movies he throws it with such
force that it seems like it weighs a lot
i also like the implications of taskmaster
having vibranium claws like black panther and
the fact that we just got the black panther
cameo scene crossover at the end of falcon and
winter soldier this past week in episode 3.
i think it was only a matter of time before they
started crossing over a lot of the black panther
movie storyline stuff with the other mcu movies
the black widow movie is actually going to be
released around the same time we're getting loki
episode 5. there's going to be six episodes total
of the loki series at least as far as i know but
if you were confused about what the whole point of
the black widow movie is it's mostly to explain
her secret backstory in why she was so willing
to sacrifice herself during avengers end game and
also for her to pass the mantle of mcu black widow
to florence pugh's black widow and connecting
this to hawkeye too florence pew is supposed
to have some cameo scenes during the hawkeye
series if you have any big questions though
or you spotted any easter eggs during this that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments there's a whole bunch
of new trailers that just got released so i'll try
to do videos for all those as fast as possible
while you wait for everything click here for
my full falcon winter soldier episode 3 video and
click here for my godzilla vs kong ending and end
credit scene video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!